garyvee welcome to the mentor thank you
for having me
gary's in the house that's pretty cool
yes it's very cool for me
thank you oh i'm a big fan of thank you
so much so
what we like to do for our audience at
least is that uh
audience loves to know a little bit
about the person i mean you know you're
a public figure
everybody probably follows you on
instagram and all the various other
places did you
put out your material but probably you
don't get that much time to hear really
about the garyvee story
sure who is gary bennetcheck like i'd
like to know you know
it's a it's a very classic immigrant
story
you know of a boy that's born in a
deeply communist country like the soviet
union
coming to america uh which is a very
capitalist
country uh in the late 70s unfortunately
there was not a very good economy at the
time when we came so
these golden streets that my parents
were promised
were even worse than they were in russia
so much so that
some fun stories have popped up recently
in my family of like even debating to go
back
seriously yeah which was kind of
interesting even for me so
you know it was a lot of struggle you
know
i always tell a lot of my friends that
i'm far more similar to their
grandfather than i am to them
because i'm because i was born in the
old country because i came over
because i worked all the time because
there was no entitlement
school was kind of almost weirdly
secondary
uh in a lot of ways school in america or
school yeah
school in america you know i wasn't a
good student and
you know for a lot of second and third
generations
school is the big play but for a lot of
first generations you're just trying to
put
food on the table and that's what my
parents did but i was so intertwined
with them
because i was born in the old world and
and
it was a very entrepreneurial story by
the time i was six or seven years old
i was selling lemonade i was shoveling
snow i was washing cars i was selling
flowers
it was what drive it like why why dna
there's nothing else you didn't have to
put
food on your own i did not it was just
more fun for me than playing
it was more fun for me when snow would
hit the ground
to go in the garage grab a shovel and
ring people's doorbells and say i will
shovel your driveway for five dollars
than it was to build a snowman or throw
or sledding
or throw snowballs at each other was it
a game it continues to be a game yeah
so even then it was a game then 100 yes
and an enjoyable game i think one of the
reasons i'm successful
and one of the things i try to push a
lot of people to think about is can you
love your process
you know if you're in this and
entrepreneurship is cool now
yeah if you're in this too cool that's
exactly right
if you're in this to flex on instagram
you're gonna lose
yeah and uh and i was doing it when it
was
in the 80s and 90s in america
entrepreneurship wasn't a thing
that was actually what in this country
people thought it was something bad in
america too
if you're a bad dude if you're an
entrepreneur you're actually a loser
living off of mommy and daddy yeah it
was it was you're exactly right
you and i know this a lot of the kids
don't know now it's like being a rapper
or an
athlete it's incredible for me to watch
what's transformed over 30 years
but i was willing to do it because it's
all i could do
i i listen to athletes actors and
actresses
singers artists and in their
documentaries inevitably they're like
well i just couldn't do anything
else and as an entrepreneur that's how i
think
so dude so do you think you know
there's a lot of hard luck stories that
i hear around you know around the world
and like mike tyson is a good example
yes he had nothing yeah and he used
sport as his way out
yes do you think entrepreneurship is a
way out
you know i think back then i think it is
for some
i do uh i don't think it was for me
i didn't feel desperate i didn't grow up
in an environment that scared me you
have choices
i did have choices to be frank i did i
could have decided to be a good student
i just loved it i love it
now i love it i mean
i woke up on the flight here from the
u.s i woke up
1am sydney time knowing that it was
probably my best interest to sleep a
little bit more to get on time here
but i but i was so happy that i woke up
because i couldn't wait to go on ebay
and look up the value of sports cards
because in the last month and really
over the last year but in the last month
i've gotten quite hot in the theory that
sports cards are about to make a
comeback
and i want to buy up as many soccer and
basketball cards as i can because i
think they're going to go up a bunch
that's an energy that i you know and i'm
going to make
no money i'll make more money speaking
in this four city tour
during this week then i will in the
countless hours i put in
over the next year trying to buy up
messy rookie cards or lebron rookie
cards
but the action of the game the what
fight see something that nobody else saw
i'm far more proud that i saw social
media
facebook twitter those things than the
money i made
by making those bets can i just
something i mean like
you're an intense dude yes and that's
cool
i'm i'm similar like but in a different
way
and a lot of people don't like it okay
and i can just see you talking about
just like the cards now
yeah what is it in the fabric of
gary vaynerchuk's life you're going to
say it's in your dna but what is it that
in your social development
that actually has formed all the layers
to get you to be so intense because you
can't be good at what you do unless
you're intense you'll love it get it
yeah but you've got to be intense
i i think think intensely i think
being on your own you know like
not having not having the uh
luxury which i think is a disadvantage
of an
over coddling nature what does that mean
being on your own
you know as soon as i was four five six
years old i'm outside playing by myself
no brothers and sisters i did but you
know they were three years younger and
11 years younger
so at first it's me and so no brothers
and sisters
uh a mother that grew up in the soviet
union where the framework was go outside
and play
the 80s when you could still do that in
america so
crossing the street playing in the woods
i mean there's
15 year olds that are being watched by
their parents more than i was watched
when i was 5.
of course it kills you because you know
exactly the vulnerability we're growing
we're living in a time where everyone's
a zoo animal
they they don't know how to live in
society because parents are such
helicopters
and eighth place trophies and you know
nobody's allowed to lose nobody's
allowed to cry
10th place saw that ribbon today so so
for me i think what's in my fabric is
having the scrap i'm from the dirt
i had no choice yeah yeah i fight yeah
and does that build your intensity
though of course everywhere
not for me no you know i'm empathetic
that it might be too much for others i
respect that
i understand that i just also can't live
my life based on other people's judgment
is mom or dad energetic by that
you know in different ways yes but
neither
like come across in the way that i do i
think i'm a pretty interesting blend of
the two
um i'm much more of a showman uh
and high energy than my father but i'm
deeply competitive
and and the work ethic my mom is not
a showman either but her side of the
family is especially the men
so you know no you know i'm different
than both my parents
but obviously because it's so easy for
me to read i understand the pieces of
the puzzle that i got from both of them
to how this happened are they proud of
you oh immensely
and that and that is up to you oh
unbelievably i'm a uncomfortable
advocate of my
parents i'm a deeply grateful
child i i really i mean i'm writing a
book in my own head that i eventually
put out called perfectly parented
you know most people hate their parents
or dwell
on their parents which is probably
not true but spend a lot of time judging
what their parents did wrong instead of
thinking about what their parents did
right i'm sure my parents did tons of
things
wrong i'm just incapable of focusing on
that i'm just so grateful for the things
they did right
so the difference between so there's a
lot of people out there i mean
you're a doer the intensity brings
effort and
with intensity you get a lot of
execution
but were you a dreamer as a kid did you
sit around dreaming did you see that
because then are you going to sell
lemonade or whatever you want to do just
sit down and plan it like you woke up
one night
speaking about your cards yes only in
the most
macro level i i very early on decided
that i was going to buy my favorite
football team
the new york jets and i've stuck to it
for 35 years at this point so yeah i
would say i dreamt about that i dreamt
about
making a mark in the wine business and
building one of the large retail
companies
in america i did that i dreamt i thought
about disrupting the ad world
in a way that they couldn't see coming
i'm putting the final pieces on that
right now so
uh i i dream currently of leaving an
incredible legacy and having
thousands of people show up to my
funeral because of the value i provided
with no ask in return
so yeah i dream i dream but
i'm too grounded in practicality
to be a talker you know i would be
embarrassed
to talk and not execute i almost put
things out
to put the pressure on making sure i
execute
so that nobody could ever play a clip
because i record everything
uh you talked a big game but you
couldn't do it now i'm fine
unbelievably fine with not achieving my
goals
i'm not fine with not trying to you're
gonna have a crack
gotta have like a real [ __ ] crack you
know what i mean
like one of the best cracks like that i
can feel
yeah i'm i love losing believe it or not
because that means i deserved it yeah
but i i love the way you delivered that
sentence
it excited me a real crack an all-time
crack
uh last breath [ __ ] it i did everything
i went as hard as i could there's
nothing left
there's nothing left i wish there was a
couple more years because i'd still be
cracking at 100
but if this is it i don't want to regret
i don't want to regret and
you have to be careful because a lot of
times one part of your life you may
leave no regret you know i spend a lot
of time trying to be thoughtful of not
being a man of the world
at the expense of my own children you
see that a lot i read a lot of
obituaries
i watch a lot of famous or no or people
of notoriety
pass and the world mourns but their kids
have very subtle
interesting yeah dad was awesome to the
world we wish we had a little you know
i re i read it i read it because i
inherently understand it
and i want to hedge against it because i
want to find the right balance
i'm aware of it um but yes
that's how i say it like a lot of people
like you get them
all the time and they're they are
dreamers i mean i've seen you interview
some of the people at some of your talks
you know they
and god love them they get up there and
they they want you to solve a problem
for them
they ask you a question and they're
looking for an answer and i see these
dreamers i mean what do you say to them
about balancing the difference between
dreaming and execution i mean how do
they how do people work out
because you've got to dream of heart a
lot and then you've got to then you've
got to stop you're going to start
executing hard a lot then you've got to
go back to dream
because your life can't be just about
executing it's going to be about
dreaming that's right you have to
strategy
you have to strategize and execute uh
without people saying you change your
mind all the time
first of all i i think changing your
mind all the time
is the core strength of a human being i
you know
people saying i said i'm just
reassessing what i'm doing my dad used
to get so mad at me
you you just said a week ago that we
were going to sell rose
i'm like am i changing my mind customers
came in i didn't like the way it felt
i changed my mind i think changing your
mind is a huge strength
i and it's funny i was about to answer
and we brought up the change of mind i
think it's the same thing i think a lot
of people don't fire people
don't change their mind because they're
greatly insecure this is an
enormous game of insecurity you know why
do people dream and not do
they're insecure they inherently don't
think they can do it the system makes us
a bit that way do i know about american
country here our regulatory environment
yes
it sort of enhances this insecurity
which puts you in the position where you
can't fire somebody
yeah [ __ ] that yeah yeah i i you know
guys here though i i'm a lot more
educated in the uk
version and i and i'm aware that the
australian version is closer to that
that is some [ __ ] horseshit yeah
and is the great vulnerability to
anything that eliminates
merit is bad yeah
if somebody sucks and you can't fire
them
you the whole thing's broken yeah the
hell are we doing here
well i might not battle with it all the
time it kills me um
and like i even did a tv show here about
what i actually had to say you're fired
and it's not very australian to do that
because it's considered uncool to fire
somebody
but in my business like i mean i'm sorry
i just can't put up with something that
doesn't work
more importantly it leads to entitlement
and entitlement is poison
yeah a hundred percent we just had a
chat about you know what sort of drove
gary gary
look one thing i want to talk about some
practical stuff now because a lot of
listeners who are
who are desperate to emulate people like
you they they actually you know
people actually love you i mean i i talk
to him i've been told a lot of people
since you're going to come on the show
everybody just wraps wraps wraps and
i've been seeing i've been following
what's going on at the uh
the three sta the three states you're
talking about on the nic
national achievers uh convention and
i've been watching all the videos
everyone's saying great stuff
but where do you advise people to say
look this is just not about me having
followers and people loving me that's
important
but where do you what do you say to
people how you actually turn it into a
business
otherwise just wasting time so i think
there's a lot of ways to do it
so you know it's really funny you and i
are super aligned with this
which is at the end of the day things
have to become practical
yeah you know and and during the break i
was saying you know you don't pay your
bills with followers and i believe that
i'm also a very interesting messenger
when it comes to this
because unlike many of my contemporaries
that kind of look like me
one of the core reasons everybody loves
me is i don't actually extract value
out of my audience now couple things
there is
nothing wrong with extracting value out
of your audience
every this is the free world nobody has
to buy your program or your offsite or
your master
you know so what's interesting about
what i do
is i build businesses that don't have to
do with my audience
right so vaynermedia works with fortune
5000 companies
yeah you know so my audience is not the
ceo of ge
so can you connect the two then can you
connect the audience i think the way i
you know it's really interesting how i
connect the audience let me give you an
example
i am it is very clear to me
that we have one to two clients at
vaynermedia right now that
client that i would argue that the
tipping point
to why they chose vaynermedia versus
is because their 17 year old son of the
decision maker thinks i'm cool
right brand got it yeah
but it's funny let me go here because i
think this will bring value to the
audience i wrote a book several years
ago that did extremely well
called jab jab jab right hook i thought
i was writing it for the opposite of who
we're talking to
this enormous group of people on the
internet who only sell
buy this by that have no interest in
value only want to do
top of the funnel and landing pages just
to convert you to their 900
ebook no soul really gross
and i was trying to teach him like hey
take a step back how about a little
romance
you don't have to try to close at the
bar at every move
you know not even now you know you know
what i mean like half these characters
on the internet are just like right at
it so
i was like hey jab jab jab give it some
value give some value give some value
then
ask don't expect what was interesting
is that's who i thought i was doing it
for what it ended up happening was it
was actually who you're going for
the people that most responded to the
book were people who were
super ideological and actually were very
frothy and almost hippie-like
building great content bringing so much
value but were actually scared to go in
for the sale
you know my great ability to both be
selfish
and selfless in balance in harmony
pulling hard from both sides has a lot
to do with what's
working for me so you know listen
at the end of the day vanity metrics
whether that's followers on instagram
whether that's
the jewelry or car you drive no matter
what it is at the end of the day
underneath all of that there needs to be
something tangible
and real and if you're not asking for
business and more importantly
if you're not selling something you
believe in you're finished
the single reason i think i'm a great
salesman as somebody who
hates to ask for a sale is because i
deeply believe in what i'm selling
whether it's the wine i produce
whether it's a sneaker collaboration i
have with k-swiss whether it's vayner
i i sit in this you know what it feels
like to sit in this room and know
[ __ ] think know that vaynermedia is the
best marketing firm in the world
it's empowering you you sell with
conviction
and i just watch way too many people uh
either be deeply insecure about what
they're selling because deep down they
know they have no idea what the [ __ ]
they're selling
they don't know that's right or they're
just broken
they just so care about money they know
exactly what they're selling
they just know they're selling [ __ ]
and they're [ __ ] preying on people's
fears
and i want to kill those [ __ ] yeah
yeah well it's funny you know because
i i always talk about this whole point
like you know i'm in a homeland business
and i wasn't home limited many years ago
with a well-known person in australia
and um he once said to me i was only i
was a young guy
and i was trying to get into by half my
business and he asked me the question
because about invest you know in those
days a lot of money 25 million into my
business
he said to me um what business you win
and uh
i said well i was about to say i'm in
the homeland business because my company
was called visit home loans
he said don't say [ __ ] home loans and
uh i was
stuffed yeah i didn't know what to say
and he said to me you know and he gave
me this he's you're not selling homeland
just selling people's hopes and dreams
that's right he said
that's what that's what your messaging
is and that's what that's what i love
doing
you know even today my other business
sells home loans we still do home loans
and i was only thinking about it today
when i was coming down the studio
i actually love lending people money to
buy a [ __ ] house
you know i i love lending money to
people because they get so happy
you know like it's and that's like if my
branches around australia put up on
instagram
a photograph of them standing next to
someone who's just with their wife and
kids whatever their arrangements are
in front of a soul sign with the key
just about walking the house that's the
best feeling i can get
when you're selling hopes and dreams and
it's practical that's amazing
unfortunately a lot of people sell the
other way they sell against people
they sell against people's insecurities
and fears i hate it
there's a great thing that somebody said
to me years ago and i
say it all the time there's two ways to
build the biggest building in town
you either just build the biggest
building in town
or you spend all your time tearing
everybody else's building down
and i think about it often maybe once a
week
and if there's anything on my last
breath that i'm most proud of
is i'm out here just trying to build the
biggest building i have no
interest in tearing anybody else's
building down and uh
watching other people navigate the other
way is uh
is intriguing for me to watch and
honestly i feel bad for them because i
know there's real poison inside that
system
sure um for me sport it's really
important
just not just it's it's the fabric of my
life but it's also something that drives
me
i always look to sport in terms of my
own businesses etc but i can't live
without sport
and i've seen some youtube stuff for you
getting involved in sport and training
with a lot of
people you know like they look like they
might be baseball
footballers over there how important
sport to you what's it do for your life
well first of all the reason i love
sports is there's no hiding
i it's why i love boxing and you brought
up mike tyson earlier
man i like boxing there's just no hiding
you know yeah and and so so
i love you know what i hate about
business there's a lot of hiding yeah
there's a you put entrepreneur on your
bio on instagram and everyone thinks you
are one
you know and so sport's important to me
because i love when it goes to triple
zero
somebody won and somebody lost i think
both of us already acted reacted in this
podcast
around the thought of like eighth place
trophies or not that
so that's important physically i love to
compete
you know what you know like if you said
let's run to the door right now you'd be
stunned what i would do like i throw the
whatever it takes i love the game as far
as physical fitness
about five to six years ago i took it
very seriously after not taking it
seriously
most of my life and it's been a great
addition especially soft tissue work my
back i hurt during the liquor store days
it's been very important but it doesn't
release stress
i'm always fascinated by people that
work out or run or
do sports where they speak about the
mental stress
relief for some reason i don't have that
but what i love is the merit god i wish
everything in life was sports
because it's just so cool you can't
cheat
you know people can talk about steroids
and enhancement drugs fine but
it's really it's it's a really pure
reality and i love that and then but
does it form part of your routine that
like i mean everyone said well what does
garyvee do when he gets up in the
morning but like what's your routine
you in terms of support yeah i mean i
work out every day
um i go to the gym i uh
so that's what i do we talk about
running
lifting weights yep but mainly lifting
weights a lot of soft tissue work that
is something that i've become a
fascia and all this kind of incredibly
game-changing for the way
some of the flaws i had i played
basketball though
you know at 43 it's starting to get to a
place where i'm a little worried about
knees and ankles and things that nature
i play a little tennis um
i uh i i don't do as much competitive
sport as i'd probably like to
um but it is something i think a lot
about of how to inter
interject it a little bit more into my
world but do you think it's do you think
it's as an entrepreneur as somebody
who's sort of running their own business
and you know like there is a lot of
[ __ ] you have to do with it for me it's
like meditative that's my well that's
that's where i was going with this
earlier i don't get that
you don't get that no uh are you still
thinking about work then when you're
training
no but but maybe
what i would say is not always you know
trying [ __ ] hard enough come on
listen i think i think i think you
appreciate this i'm [ __ ] doing
everything hard
it's just it's you know it's funny i'm
gonna answer it this way
and i've been thinking a lot about it
for the last four years as as meditation
has grown in popularity
which is great because i love seeing
people find balance
in the tactic i would argue that i'm
meditating at all times
and i don't know what exactly i'm saying
right now but
intuitively man i feel super
like i'm almost talking i'm almost
having conversation with myself while
i'm having one with you
um yeah i don't know what it is i'm very
grateful for it
i'm in really interesting harmony and
balance for the
i've i'm in a very funny framework i'm
basically in one place
if eight people didn't die today
everything else is good
i've gotten very i don't know if that
was my great-grandmother my grandmother
was a very russian thing
like every single thing we blessed to
everything was health
health you know everybody died so young
in russia it was a miserable place
um alcoholism at scale communism is bad
uh but i'm pretty much in the place of
i don't need that much of a mental
release for my work
i actually am not that anxious about it
i was gonna say it's because
is everything going good then yeah but
even when it's to going back i don't
think i like
money do you have bad times
i have things that i have only time i
have bad times
is when i have to hurt somebody by
firing them
yeah you know like i hate that
but like when somebody's firing you
should see
me on a phone call or a meeting getting
fired by a client
it is hilarious they start it i know
exactly what's happening
and i basically bail them out within
five seconds
but in a sweet way full accountability
yeah don't worry about
you know like i'm out of here yeah let's
say i need the 18 minutes back
to go how do you fire someone in your
environment how do you what do you say
what do you say
i this has been the greatest chances do
you give him oh
i give them too many yeah i would argue
for as much as i hate entitlement i'm
very good at creating it within my
workforce
but i've gotten a lot better i really
needed the lesson of this last company
somewhere around year six of vaynermedia
i looked around and said
oh [ __ ] everything i despise i've
created
i've over coddled this organization i've
put too much on my shoulders
and my my deep anger and dislike for
conflict has created entitlement and i
had to go through a recourse
and the and the entitled kids weren't
ready for it
and it was painful but
radical candor is not something that
came natural to me
i'd rather stun you by firing you and
giving you a great severance
than giving you critical feedback along
the way it was just my framework and
it's something i've had to work on
i'm a much stronger operator today today
i had a couple conversations last month
that i just can't believe i'm the one
having them
i'm being so transparent i'm not over
coddling it
i'm not sugar coating it and it's super
unnatural for me
i do not like micro conflict uh i'm a
tough guy on video and the stage but
when it comes to one on one
i'm a honey over vinegar guy but i've
had to get better and i want to be
better and so
i've gotten the conversations have
become far more transparent a lot
one thing that i struggle with is
feedback from other managers because i
think they're incentivized
to undermine their own direct reports
so i'm quite cynical to senior
management
giving me feedback on people underneath
them so the reason people get a lot of
chances
is because i don't make the mistake that
most people do which is blindly take
the word of their direct report as an
indicator because i actually think they
have more to lose
and sometimes suppress the people
underneath them there's a big question i
get asked all the time
how do you do this so you're saying to
me then you go to the individual who
you go you go past the direct report the
boss
the manager and you go to the individual
go and suss it out for yourself
not only do i do that i follow everybody
on social media i read slack
i'm doing a lot of recon to make sure i
have a clear picture because i think
most people's vulnerability at scale
is they blindly take the information
from the most senior person
who inherently has more to lose and i
think
leads to bad behavior because and in
your environment
you i just for me i will not cop it but
that upward management so in other words
i'm managing you're my boss i'm managing
you
on your expectations of me it gets a
little fluffy there
so i have to not necessarily that yeah
but not blind belief that the manager
said this person sucks i'm like yeah
let's see about that
well i i i what i'm shitty about
actually i'll pretend right now why i'm
really [ __ ] pissed off is we have to
finish
i don't mind telling you that but i know
you're on a tight schedule so i'm going
to ask you this is a really important
question to me
when gary vaynerchuk retires or goes off
from the sunset and goes and lives
next door to richard branson what do you
want to be remembered for
that i gave more than i took i really
want to be remembered for that
it's interesting when i watch you i see
you are you are very generous at
actually at a massive speed when you
speak on youtube and various other
places
and i think it's actually it and i
wonder i was actually curious
is that generosity is that you wanting
to give more than you take
what more than you receive and do you
think that
you've you've achieved that so far if
you thought today
i i think so i i think that
the thing that alpha winners like you
that are very close to me and know
a lot of details are surprised by is how
much i'm not driven by the thing that
most
i share many things with many of you but
i just am not in it
for the things that i thought i was in
it as a kid what ended up happening was
being a millionaire or a billionaire i'm
just
i'm just not in it for the money i i'll
take it i want it
i want to buy the jets but [ __ ] i would
much rather be known who i am versus
others
i could easily get the jets if i could
switch to being a more selfish
individual
i don't know if anybody can extract more
value out of humans than me
it just i got very lucky in my opinion
that that is not my framework
and i enjoy the admiration versus the
extra zero in my bank account
well for me that's really refreshing
that's i i love that answer that's
fantastic and i have to say to the
people listening to the show when gary
walked in
i expected a like uh an anthony robbins
moment with like
lots of noise and and he came in very
humble and he introduced himself to
everybody in the cast here
everybody and uh to me in our country at
least
that's refreshing and that's very
australian for us and
i appreciate it thank you for saying
that thank you so much
real pleasure
you